here we see pure consciousness posited
in a two-fold manner once as the
restless movement to and fro all its
it's moments aware in them of an other
nasubi seated in the act of grasping it
and again rather as the tranquil unity
certain of its own truth for this unity
that movement is the other welfare this
movement that tranquil unity is the
other and consciousness and object
alternate within these reciprocal
determinations thus on the one hand
consciousness finds itself moving about
searching here and there its object
being the pure in itself in essence on
the other hand it knows itself to be the
simple category and the object is the
movement of the different moments
consciousness however as essence is this
whole process itself of passing out of
itself as simple category into a
singular individual into the object and
of contemplating this process in the
object nullifying the object is distinct
from it appropriating it as its own and
proclaiming itself as this certainty of
being all reality of being both itself
and its object
in paragraph 237 of the phenomenology we
see a exchange between two polarities
which should actually remind us of the
section that we just Traverse which is
the unhappy consciousness we see a
splitting into two of consciousness
itself but what's happening here is a
bit more integrated or unified you can
say we don't see the the generation of
something that's far off that really is
consciousness but consciousness doesn't
recognize it as such
instead in this reason section both of
these aspects are going to be connected
together in consciousness as such so let
us see how Hegel does this he talks
about pure consciousness being positive
in a two-fold manner and these are the
two parts to that where the two aspects
on the one hand we have movement right
yeah uses this this term Restless no one
is going to translate it as the opposite
of that being tranquil you know that
that's Ruthie at Monrovia you know so
they're just opposites of each other in
this case we have movement in this case
we have counter pose to movement unity
right so consciousness as day of
restless movement not just a movement
that goes wherever and you know into
whatever it wants to be with with no
sort of purposiveness
or or development and stuff this is a
process that has been going on that
we've seen this dialectical progression
so consciousness is a restless movement
through all of its moments this is one
aspect of consciousness it's gone
through you know the consciousness
section with perception and forcing the
understanding you know these various
dialectical developments that took place
in there it's gone through this entire
self consciousness section which is
working out its relationship with the
other now in terms of
season it is doing so in terms of
consciousness and world and so
consciousness is going to go through all
of these movements it's not quite
finished close to finish yeah and what's
going on in this Hegel says it is an
awareness of other deaths but it's an
awareness of other 'no stand as soon as
it starts to wrap its head around the
other as such it supersedes it it is
engaged in this process of you know
subletting it or overcoming it so
there's one side right there on the
other side there's consciousness as a
tranquil unity as it says aware of its
own truth so there's a a resting place
right a little bit later he's going to
say that this is consciousness that
knows itself to be the simple category
that we saw discussed in the last two
paragraphs here on this part it's going
to be seeking the pure in itself and the
essence and you might say well where is
that period self in essence is that here
you know certain way it is this is also
by the way taking this to be its object
this is taking this to be its object but
what's really going on is this entire
process all of this angel it's going to
tell us it is really consciousness so
you know like I said there's a splitting
that's taking place here but it's not a
complete separation he says that what
happens in this is each of these is
other to the the other right so for for
consciousness is tranquil unity the
movement itself is other for this
consciousness as restless movement
consciousness is a tranquil even it is
other and it's it's an other that ends
up being superseded in the process as
well so he says on the one hand
consciousness
itself moving about searching here and
there the object being the pure in
itself in essence on the other nose
itself to be the simple category and the
object is the movement to the different
moments consciousness as essence is this
whole process itself so what is this
what does the essence are in itself that
it's seeking it thinks that it's this
tranquil unity of consciousness but it's
really the totality of consciousness
which includes consciousness as Restless
movements so it doesn't realize itself
that this is part of the essence that it
is seeking he goes a little bit further
and he says that it passes out of itself
a simple category into a singular
universal right into the object and of
contemplating this process in the object
nullifying the object is distinct from
it appropriating it as its own
this is appropriation is going to be
core to the activity of reasons think of
reason is ever you know appropriating
more and more conquering more and more
it's going to a kind of will to to
devour the world and transform it into
to what is speaking to it what is
rational what it would fix itself so he
says it proclaims itself as a certainty
of being all reality being both itself
and its object and we saw that this is
something that is really integral to the
nature of consciousness when we're
talking about the Galleon idealism or
this this progress of reasons it is in
fact something that is taking other
things as its object but saying that
those are its object precisely because
they are for consciousness so in a
certain sense it is a relation to itself
as consciousness so all of this is
involved here and notice how big of a
difference this is from the you know
ever trying to chase the the
unchangeable or the tranquil unity that
we saw in the on
be consciousness
it's first declaration is only this
abstract empty phrase that everything is
its own for the certainty of being all
reality is at first only the pure
category this reason which first
recognizes itself in the object finds
expression in the empty idealism which
grasps reason only as it first comes on
the scene and fancies that by pointing
out this pure mind of consciousness in
all being and by declaring all things to
be sensations or ideas that has
demonstrated this mind of consciousness
to be complete reality it is bound
therefore to be at the same time
absolute empiricism for in order to give
filling to the empty mind that is to get
hold of difference with all its
developed formations its reason requires
an extraneous impulse in which first is
to be found the multiplicity of
sensations and ideas this idealism
therefore becomes the same kind of self
contradictory ambiguity as skepticism
except that while this expresses itself
negatively the former does so positively
but it fails equally with skepticism to
bring together its contradictory
thoughts of pure consciousness being all
reality while the extraneous impulse or
sensations and ideas are equally reality
instead of bringing them together it
shifts from one to the other and is
caught up in the spirit that is the
sensuous infinite since reason is all
reality in the sense of the abstract
mind and the other is for its something
and different and extraneous what is
here made explicit is there kind of
knowing of an other by reason which we
met with in the form of meaning
perceiving and the understanding which
apprehends what is meant and what is
perceived such a knowing is at the same
time pronounced by the very principle of
this idealism not to be a true knowing
for only in the unity of that perception
lies the truth of knowing the pure
reason of this idealism in order to
reach this other which is essential to
it and thus is the in itself but which
it does not have within it is therefore
thrown back by its own self onto that
knowing which is not a knowing of what
is true in this way it condemns itself
of its own knowledge and volition to
being
and untrue kind of knowing and cannot
get away from meaning and perceiving
which for it have no truth it is
involved in a direct contradiction it
asserts essence to be a duality of
opposed factors the unity of a
perception and equally a thing whether
the thing is called it an extraneous
impulse or an empirical or sensuous
entity or the thing in itself it still
remains in principle the same that is
extraneous to that unity
this paragraph number 238 is a very rich
one in terms of it's suggestive
implications when you're reading thread
on the one hand you can see Hegel
talking about things like idealism
empiricism skepticism and it's not only
tempting but I think actually legitimate
to try to identify this or at least
connect it with certain movements and
and figures within philosophy in modern
philosophy reaching up to the Hegel's
time which he's trying to move past
notice that he's going to speak about
empty idealism by contrast to the kind
of idealism that he himself is trying to
work out which presumably is not going
to be idealism in the standard sense in
which it's merely opposed to materialism
or empiricism or skepticism or whatever
you like it's been you have to encompass
them the other thing that I'd like to
say about this is that I think that and
you're reading through this this
paragraph in particular and as you look
at what I've got here on the chalkboard
sort of schema sizing the movement and
and the different moments that Hegel is
dealing with you should ask yourself
about the location of three things that
he's going to reference in here one is
well where does reason capital R
actually fit in here
how does that play its role is is that
identified with any one of these things
or is it the whole process itself the
you know moments that are connected
together and opposed to each other in
this another thing they ask you about
another R word where is reality where is
what is taken to be foundational or most
important remember we're doing this for
consciousness this is a phenomenology so
we want to see how consciousness is
actually grasping things how things are
consciousness but at some point we don't
want it merely to be phenomenology in
the sense of just being about
appearances we want to get at some sort
of metaphysical basis some sort of
metaphysical reality something that has
essence as Hegel calls it right and then
the third thing they ask is you know
this one it might seem very obvious so
you just let's put it over here but
maybe it doesn't fit there where is as
Hegel is going to refer to it the unity
of that perception using this this term
that is very important in a common sense
but using it in a somewhat different way
so let's pick this paragraph a little
bit long let's let's work our way
through it
25-point he says in its first its first
declaration is only this empty this
abstract empty phrase that everything is
it something to say about reason right
for the certainty of being all reality
is at first only the pure category we
saw that worked through in the earlier
paragraphs in this section ultimately we
got to this you know rather enigmatic
category of the singular individual
which we're going to have to explore as
we go onto your reason and so you know
category itself is a little bit murky at
this point and he says this reason which
first recognizes itself in the object
finds its expression in empty idealism
which grasps reason only as it first
comes out the scene fancies then by
pointing out this pure mind and I you
notice I've got the eye here in
parentheses after the mind up until this
point we've really been talking about
the pure I haven't we you know that's
what made it easy to say well the unity
of that perception must be over here in
the pure eye of consciousness now
consciousness is asserting something
like well this is not only for me but
existing within my consciousness that's
where it's being is this is a very
important
here let's let's you know stress the
difference between saying I have an idea
of something which is external to me and
my idea is just sort of a dim copy of it
or something like that and what that
thing out there is insofar as I know it
at all is really my idea those are very
different positions right 110 is indeed
a kind of empiricism I know the object
because it is out there and I experience
it in some way and my ideas I hope that
they're somehow connected with it or you
know mirror it in some way but I don't
really know at all because I can't ever
grasp the thing out there by itself
why is idealism so attractive because it
holds out the possibility that what
we're really knowing is what is ours
something that we can be assured of
we've seen how important certainty is
for Hegel but we want to know whether we
have the truth of that certainty let's
go on so he says if fancies by pointing
out this pure line of consciousness
about being and declaring all things to
be sensations or ideas these are being
used not on a very technical sense here
so don't try to read in an entire pistol
mala ji Hangul is just merely signalling
the fact that you know we have you know
what we call sensations or perceptions
things that we we say that we grasp the
outside world with the external world
like you know my jacket being gray and
really it's a whole bunch of different
colors mixed in together if you looked
at it carefully those are sensations
right I don't know maybe it's one our
ideas I'm you know I'm just going to
give you a few examples freedom is an
idea all right
can you directly observer freedom in the
sense of perceiving it
not really right but it is something
that we take to be real in some sense
unless you're a doubter about freedom
Hegel's not by the way and so that's
something that we could have an idea or
reason itself can be understood to be an
idea so what does it mean that
saying that the pure mind takes those
takes things beings to be just these
means that it it encompasses them within
the scope of consciousness think for
example about Rene Descartes and the
famous Cartesian coach Ito when people
think of the coach Ito they almost
automatically as a coach or a result
right well that's an important thing but
that's only the the very start of the
whole process by which the current is
going to reason his way to an external
world then we can have not only
knowledge of but scientific knowledge of
by way of knowing you know metaphysical
truths such as there exist some sort of
perfect being let's call it God in the
hearts case and you know that one exists
as part of this this process right the
family the one is located between pure
being and nothingness is also a fruit of
date cards meditations but much more
importantly think about this in his
discussions of you know I think
therefore I am
what does he immediately move to it's
not that he's going to just dwell on the
fact that he exists and evil you know
demon or genius is deceiving him he must
exist that's that's interesting but he
leaves that behind very quickly he wants
to know what it is to be a thing that
thing's a thing whose essence is to be
thought a thing who you know primarily
exists as something that that engages in
fun and he says that it's to have for
example sensations but the sensations
don't necessarily conform to things that
are out there that's where you know for
example the evil demon could be putting
things into my head or I could just be
deceived you know about what my senses
are providing to me because the senses
all they do is transmit impulses they
don't actually provide me with the the
thing itself did it what I know what I
have touched
it is only that image that I have are
our passions our emotions Descartes will
say are actually going to be something
that we think they are types of thoughts
they're connected with the body but
there's thoughts willing and willing
against all of these sorts of things are
parts or within the scope of thought for
Hegel he's not going to talk in terms of
thought he's going to talk in terms of
consciousness and that is exactly the
sort of thing that we're talking about
here if we think about an empiricist
like john locke for example now i know
john locke is is an empiricist but he is
also very rationalist in certain
respects as well so some things can't
fit over here people's gonna say that
empiricism is trying to tell us that you
know what's gotten into our head has
come from from the outside and you know
we may have operated on it but we did so
with things that we're coming and
originally from from the outside
look at this John Locke's position and
you can see John Locke is in a certain
way counter posed to the position of a
Descartes or you know any of the other
rationalists so let's go on with us he
this is a very fascinating discussion
here right it says it's demonstrate it's
declared all things to be sensations or
ideas it's demonstrated this mind of
consciousness to be complete reality
that's what a mistaken form of idealism
does this would be an idealism that
people worry about falling into a solar
system saying that only the subject
exists right only the self exists this
is not Eagles idealism he goes
underneath says it's bound there for it
to be at the same time here's where the
transformation happens absolute
empiricism so how is it that idealism in
this sense is really a kind of
empiricism well there's a little bit of
a hidden process going on there he says
in order to give fill into the empty
mind in order to get hold of differ
it's enhanced II have something coming
in from the outside because this he says
its reason requires extraneous impulse
in which is first to be found the
multiplicity sensations and ideas and I
put thing here just to be a very generic
I'm not asserting that these are
substances or but there's something
coming from the outside and that
something is actually impinging upon the
pure mind giving it sensations and ideas
so it's not entirely wrapped up in its
own head how do we know this well could
it is thought of all the stuff on its
own even they Kurt says no Descartes
says if I were so perfect as to you know
have given myself all this I wouldn't
have any doubts this is roughly
paraphrasing right and we can see the
same thing arise as a problematic over
and over again throughout the centuries
leading up to him so he says this
idealism therefore becomes the same kind
of self contradictory ambiguity as
skepticism the skepticism that we went
through in the stoicism skepticism and
the unhappy consciousness section where
what was characteristic of skepticism it
was not able to arrive and an integrated
view of things and even its own doubts
and even its own negations turned out to
be in a certain way contradictory so
when reason as empty idealism as a
reason you know first arriving on the
scene tries to assert that everything is
really you know within its own
consciousness within its own purview it
has to acknowledge this and then the
question is well how do you actually
reconcile the two of these together this
this self contradictory analog the
skepticism is not going to work he says
that skepticism expresses itself
negatively the skeptic says I can't
really be sure of anything even sure of
the fact that I can't
anything reason however does so
positively he says I feels equally
though to bring together its
contradictory thoughts of pure
consciousness being all reality you
remember what I ain't what I said before
we should ask yourself where is reality
in this is it just on this side or is it
just on this side can't be here because
this is you know ultimately
self-contradictory is it somehow in the
connection between them there's the
answer where it is reason lie
also in this connection between them as
well so but the reason he has to realize
that he goes on and he says instead of
bringing them together it shifts from
one to the other and it gets caught up
in the Spiritist that is the sensuous
infinite so it wavers in between these
two it just goes oscillating back and
forth and that was the movement that we
saw carried out with skepticism this is
not a way to make in advance so he says
since reason is all reality in the sense
of the abstract mind and the other for
it is something indifferent and
extraneous what is here made explicit is
that kind of knowing of another by
reason which we met in earlier
progressions so we're retracing once
again the dialectical movements involved
in said certainty and the meaning he
says here in perception or the thing in
its qualities right and in force and the
understanding when we dealt with not
only the conception of force and the
understanding but also the conception of
remember world and we had not only you
know the observable world the world of
appearances but we have the world of
laws behind that the supersensible world
and the inverted world and somehow these
were all part of the same world so that
same sort of breeding multiple visions
like that together has to occur with
this and it's not yet occurring where
are we going to move out of this he says
this kind of knowing is at the same time
pronounced by the very principle of this
idealism not to be a true
that is the the knowing that's
associated with the understanding for
only in the unity mana perception lies
the truth of no now here's that question
where should we locate the unity of that
perception the rationalists and taunt is
very much a rationalist in this respect
are going to locate it here right thing
Hegel is not the unity of that
perception is somehow going to have to
encompass all of us which means that it
is not merely on the side of the subject
but also encompassing the object you
might say how is it any different than
what conscious is saying about you know
the world of existing for me well you
know we're going to see that play itself
out but let me let me just give you a
sort of a little teaser about that what
does compound lying behind the scenes of
the appearances the appearances are
really all we can know but we can
certainly think beyond the appearances
or at least hope beyond the appearances
it's the thing in itself for Hegel there
isn't going to be any inaccessible thing
in itself behind the appearances that we
cannot make progress into that's not to
say that appearances are all that we
have or any sort of silliness like that
it's to say something much more profound
which is that reason human reason or at
least you know as we move forward into
spirits and you know absolutely knowing
is able to penetrate into all of reality
and making its own or sort of recuperate
its relationship with it but he goes on
he says the pure reason of this ideal is
in order to to reach this other which is
essential to it and thus is the in its
own
which it does not have within it is
through back by its own self onto that
knowing which is not a knowing of what
is true so it wants to keep everything
on this side it realizes there's also
something on this side it wants to have
what that is and throws itself back over
here it cannot be satisfied in doing so
so he says in this way it condemns
itself in its own knowledge no notice
this key phrase it condemns itself in
its own knowledge just you know
speculative or theoretical an activity
of the intellect and it volition to
being an untrue kind of knowing why
bring up Alishan there we see that with
Hegel the theoretical and the practical
can be distinguished but are never truly
dissociated from each other the entire
driving force of the dialectical
development is you might say the working
out of practical reason practical reason
is motivated not only by a desire to
know a desire to grasp what is most
fundamental or important or to
systematize but to do things to react to
values to embody the good to resist the
evil that we could go on and on and on
about that for Hegel practical reason
and theoretical reason or speculative
reason or if you'd like to talk pure
reason which is you know doesn't even
make sense in a Hegelian form they're
fused together they fit in with each
other this is a very important thing to
keep in mind as we move into later
sections of Reason so he says it
condemns itself to being an untrue kind
of knowing it cannot get away from
meaning and perceiving which word have
no truth it's involved in direct
contradiction it asserts essence to be a
duality of opposed factors that you
a perception and equally I think the
things is why I chose the word thing
over here right thing is something
that's supposed to be object outside of
ourselves and yeah the unity of a
perception is itself Hegel say is it's
saying here a thing because it has
self-consciousness it is reflexive it
can treat itself as a thing it is only
possible for the human being to view
itself as a thing because it is more
than a thing in doing so right we saw
this with the self-consciousness section
it says whether the thing is called an
extraneous impulse or an empirical or
sensuous entity or not you turn the
thing in itself it still remains in
principle the same that is extraneous to
that unity the challenge then is how to
recuperate them how to reconcile that
how to make that part of this larger
unity which it already is but has not
yet been explicitly worked out in its
notion
this idealism is involved in this
contradiction because it asserts the
abstract notion of reason to be the
truth
consequently reality directly comes to
before it a reality that is just as much
not that of reason while reason is at
the same time supposed to be all reality
this reason remains of restless
searching and in its very searching
declares that the satisfaction of
finding is a sheer impossibility actual
reason however is not so inconsistent as
that on the contrary being at first only
the certainty that it is all reality it
is aware in this notion that kua
certainty qua I it is not yet in truth
reality and it is impelled to raise to
its its certainty to truth and to get
filling to the empty mind
paragraph 239 brings this initial
portion of this massive you know 200
plus paragraph reason section to an end
and it's very short but it's quite
important because it's going to sketch
out for us in very brief outline the
path that we're gonna have to go on and
what I've got you on board is the
problematic as Hegel hasn't has now
developed it particularly in the last
paragraph you can identify each of these
these points here with you know
empiricism idealism and skepticism that
we just talked about but he's also going
to show us the path forward and and what
gives us the path toward a fundamental
realization so it says the idealism
involved in this cup is involved in this
contradiction why because it asserts the
abstract notion of reason to be the
truth and remember we're talking about
truth not just as you know what is
expressed in a proposition and that
happens to be the case even if it
happens to be their general proposition
we're talking about the true and
something that on the one hand
consciousness can Congrats as true and
true is something that is encompassing
something that rounds our grasp of the
true as the truth I know that's a little
bit confusing to stay but you know it'll
get clearer as as we go on so we've got
this contradiction involved in what
Hegel is called empty idealism not not
the the kind of idealism that he himself
is proposing so what is the
contradiction I have two things here
that sort of directly contradict each
other
and then there is how the contradiction
expresses itself so on the one hand as
he says reality comes to be a reality
for reason which is not of reason right
there there's something to reality that
escapes the grasp of reason and why is
that a problem
well because we've asserted in idealism
that reason is supposed to be all
without exception all
Galip and now I put in parentheses here
this word already because that is going
to cue us into legal solution to this
right just keep that in mind now what is
the outcome of this he says that reason
becomes a restless searching and
declares satisfaction and finding any
sort of answer or conclusive thing to be
impossible this is the the skeptic part
right and so we have these three moments
of the contradiction that's a
problematic situation and so if that's
what idealism really amounts to throw
idealism out this is why Cagle has said
and earlier on idealism in the way that
many people are expressing it is you
know unbelievable comprehensible crazy
time right how is Hegel going to get us
out of this well that's gotta be wrong
if our assumption here let us into
problems then we have to do something
different this is where you talks about
actual reason it says actual reason is
not so inconsistent is that on the
contrary being at first only the
certainty that it is a reality notice
he's got we have asserting reason to be
the true asserting reason to be a kind
of certainty right truth certainty not
the same thing certain that it's all
reality he says it's a we're in this
notion that has certainty quantity qua i
it is not yet in truth reality so
certainty and truth at this point reason
being all reality they're not
acquainting to each other and what do we
have to do in that case we could say oh
well we're done they don't equate to
each other we don't have to go any
further
or we to take Hegel's payoff which is to
say he said it simple to raise it
certainty to truth and get filling to
the empty mind this is why the already
is there reason has
reason in history of course has already
done it that's why Hegel can look back
on reason at this point in the
phenomenology he has not done that and
realizing that it has not done that yet
means that there isn't really this
contradiction that you know has been
worked out and assumed to be through the
the be-all and end-all of positions here
instead the actual reason has to get
away from the merely abstract and move
into more and more concrete dialectical
progressions and shapes of consciousness
that is what is going to happen in the
sections to come